[Music]
on
time
[Music]
x
we want to raise a very simple song
titled dona nobis pacem which
means give us peace to ask for peace
in ukraine and in all the other
forgotten wars since choirs have a
social function  that sometimes it is not
known but it is very important, it is not
only in the musical part but in the
emotional part and I believe that we have the
capacity to transmit messages in a
different way from the rest of society
because music is capable of making
people  people come to connect much
more
[Applause]
and to your goal without further
ado, after denying, incredible
, however, none of
that has been experienced and two castles are the
key to our lines
[Music]
and
wallis people
bing
on
the
floor because it is very emotional, very emotional
because I have been used to singing
for many years but it excites me, it
excites me, a very special energy is created
and this energy hopefully helps
all these people who are suffering
so much in these  moments
[Music]
[Applause]